excellent very good well thanks so much
for having me here and actually this is
my realize this is my fourth talk at
Berkeley this year but they've all been
different so but I think Berkeley is
definitely working me hard make sure I
always have a new paper an old paper
this is actually an older paper and when
I was trying to decide what to well
older but yet I'm still working on it so
this is the world of economics empirical
work where we spend four years or five
years writing a paper but I what I was
thinking about what to present today I
was looking at the schedule and sort of
thinking about the broad range of things
covered and I felt like it would be good
to give a paper that was really kind of
in the heart and soul of the way that
economists have been working with data
in a way that's sort of a little bit
different than what some of the other
disciplines have been and in particular
the way that we use this this work is
going to use modeling assumptions more
so I actually wanted to start out by
just taking a little bit of a cue from
Duncan's title from yesterday sadly I
had to teach three hours yesterday so I
wasn't able to make it but I saw talking
about sort of problem driven social
science and I really liked that title I
don't really know what he said but I'm
sure it was all good anyways one of the
things that group said before I really
had this passion for Big Data I was
helping organize the economics
professions field around market design
and one of the reasons that I was really
drawn to that area is because it's
really a multi multi method approach and
so in economics people are actually
probably more than so than some other
disciplines tend to be very narrow in
the methods that they use not even just
you know when I was a junior faculty I
was told my empirical work wouldn't
count for my tenure because I was a
theorist and even within empirical work
you you're you're like religion A or B
or C but you you don't often do all of
them together and I've always been more
interested in like using the best method
for for a problem and so market design
was one of those areas where we would
have conferences that actually had
theory and experiments
and empirical work of all different
stripes and we didn't even really
comment on it I think part of that was
because we were all trying to solve a
problem and so I think that being
organizing around a problem just kind of
breaks all of the barriers down and that
was certainly my experience working with
Microsoft when you know like you're
trying to build a product or make
something work you're gonna try it you
you just want to make it work as well as
possible and people tend to lose their
religion at least a little bit so just a
bunch of different large important real
world markets that have been designed
and analyzed in interdisciplinary
collaborations you know residency
matching school choice and kidneys these
are all things that al Roth and Parag
Pathak and a bunch of other economists
have worked on in very close
collaboration with policy makers where
they've really changed the market design
spectrum auctions and then you know more
recently like ad auction 'he's an
economist redesigned the uber surge
prices and so these are cases where
we're economists are working very
closely there were the policy makers who
sort of owned the design or the
engineers who build it and so then in
economics I'm going kind of bring out
this sort of methodological theme let me
talk about some of the different
empirical methodologies that are used
and again you with in economics we
people have often very very strong
religions about what they do and how
they do it so I mean you can sort of
start with sort of descriptive work
which is like facts and correlations so
like Matt Jen Scouse has very nice work
about empirical news browsing any shows
well people who read extreme news also
read news from the other side of the
political spectrum so those are kind of
facts that might be important for then
driving further work that is a minority
you typically don't get published in the
top economics journals for descriptive
work but occasionally if it's an
important set of facts you will the next
set of things is like theory testing so
like in some of my work I've tested
whether you know first and first price
auctions are sending auctions raise more
revenue which ones attract more small
bidders now to make those kinds of
pretty of tests those kinds of
predictions of theory you do need to
assume all else equal so in my setting
there was actually random assignment of
the auction mechanism
they like like drew balls that have urns
to figure out what kind of option to run
that's relatively rare and then that
style of work sometimes people aren't
quite as careful about their statistical
assumptions they make a very large
literature and this has sort of a
stronger religion around it is sort of
causal estimation of policy so this
tends to be like what happened when we
changed the minimum wage you know that's
a that's a huge one just by itself huge
literature what's the effect of a labor
training program and it's generally
what's what's kind of distinguishes this
is that it is a policy you're estimating
effect of an actual policy like giving
mosquito nets to people in Africa
changing class size in Africa you know
giving food at school these are and
you're estimating the effect of the
actual policy and so generally some
people got the policy and some people
don't if you're lucky you do randomized
experiments and then even within this
literature there's a little bit of a war
between people who think they should
only do experiments and people who think
that we might be able to use
observational data to answer those
questions you always need some
assumptions because the Holland's
fundamental problem of causal inference
that is you don't know if you don't
observe the same unit with him without
the treatment I can't know what would
have happened to you if you had not had
a bed net because you had a bed net and
so you must have an assumption there I
mean at a fundamental level there's a
missing data problem I don't see you in
both states of the world
so there's always assumptions you don't
they're not very strong if you ran a
randomized experiment if you didn't
things like unconfoundedness that is you
observe all of the confounders that
might be high dimensional and
instrumental variables is also a super
popular technique in economics where you
have something like the draft lottery
number that makes you more likely to
enter the military it doesn't directly
determine whether you go in the military
but it changes your probability and so
the the frontier right now in
econometrics in this thing is trying to
bring this into high dimensions that's
my most active area of research right
now I just posted a paper on archives
yesterday about high dimensional and
confounded nests have also been working
on heterogeneous treatment effects and
so on combining machine learning and
econometrics then the last area which I
think is less well known across the
interdisciplinary audiences and that's
what I'm gonna do
structural modeling and in structural
modeling York you're actually make a few
more assumptions beyond the statistical
assumptions you're typically going to
make assumptions about people's behavior
and from their behavior if you if you
you you're gonna infer something about
their preferences so why would you do
that well what if I want to make a
prediction about what happens if I
change my auction format what if I want
to make a prediction about some policy
that's never been implemented at all
what if I want to look at the welfare
effects of target and and and Walmart
merging I'm staples and Office Depot
those types of questions economists are
asked to answer in the fact that they
get paid a lot of money to answer those
and in court cases a big business is
like helping the DOJ or the FCC decide
whether to allow mergers and we're those
are those are worlds where you cannot
validate the the thing because it hasn't
happened yet and you want to figure out
well fair that is I want have no firm
profits I want to know people's these
consumer utility and how could I
possibly know how you feel right I mean
that's what I'm measuring I'm measuring
how you feel well the only way I can
possibly do that is I need to assume
that your choices reveal something about
how you feel so that's a behavioral
assumption that your choices were
optimal if I don't make any assumptions
I obviously can't measure how much worse
off you are Nora can if I don't make any
assumptions about the firm's I can't
obviously can't predict how much they're
gonna raise their prices so we're kind
of put into this bucket not because like
we love making assumptions but because
we were asked these questions and
they're gonna answer it like I mean I
was asked in my house like what would
happen if we got Yahoo's search business
how many advertisers will we get how
much will revenue go up they're gonna
make a thirty billion dollar decision
based on that number and you're gonna
you got to come up with something so so
so we do it because we have to and we
and there's been a lot of trying work to
try to relax assumptions test
assumptions and everything else this
could be a Bayesian or frequenters model
my model today is going to be Bayesian
okay so then now let's so now let me
dive into the problem at hand I'm going
to talk about advertisers on bing and so
in terms of these structural models
where this paper is new from an economic
literature perspective is that typically
one reason that this some religions
didn't like each other and you cannot
mix is that people didn't like the idea
of making all these behavioral
assumptions so my first take at kind of
advertising auctions would say well as a
structural economist what would I do I'm
going to assume the firm's or profit
maximizing and I'm gonna figure out if
their bids were optimal I can figure out
what their values would have been and I
can predict what would happen if I make
a change and that was the question I was
asked so I needed to do that but those
models didn't do very well predicting
they just kind of ran into some real bad
empirical facts like half the
advertisers didn't change their bids at
all over like a two-month period and
that obviously any rational model their
world was changing they weren't changing
you know I was failing miserably on half
the advertisers because I was predicting
that they would change so I was just
making really bad assumptions and
furthermore if you kind of talked to the
advertisers which I also was kind of
part of the work I was doing at
Microsoft you you saw that they were
using these tools and they were putting
in all sorts of other objectives into
their bidding strategies computers were
bidding on their behalf and not the way
that I was putting them in the model so
that both made the model predict badly
and it also made the engineers I'm not
so convinced by my model and because I
was economists the fact that this is
what people always did carried zero
weight at all so I needed to make my
model better and so that's kind of what
we set out to do so generally though I
mean the part of the reason we needed
this why were they asked me to do it
well the markets are actively designed
reserve prices matching algorithms
scoring algorithms all are things that
are getting changed all the time and all
of these change advertiser behavior so
if I if I do better click prediction
that means that I'm going to accurately
predict that people aren't going to
predict on some ads that's actually
going to thin out my auction and that
has an effect that the bidders should
reduce their bids for example so if I
don't predict that my short try maybe
tests give me garbage and in like a lot
of cases the short term maybe tests that
don't don't account for these long term
responses go in exactly the opposite
direction of what should happen and
actually I have I have a whole huge
talks I'd give about this because this
is a huge passion of mine
that all these large tech firms are sort
of innovating in the wrong direction
sort of systematically because they only
measure short-term effects and it's it's
bad generally you can think of all the
mistakes you make on the user side from
doing that but it's just horrible on the
on the advertiser seller side okay so um
so then because of this because but you
can I have other research on doing on
trying to fix these problems with better
short-term measures surrogates
advertiser level experimentation that's
noisy the power is terrible it's
expensive it's disruptive it's slow the
advertisers don't like it so the
structural models can be one another
tool in the toolkit so how does this
work in in advertising well so what
happens the user enters the query the
deliverer engine is gonna query the
database to get the apical bids there's
gonna be a scoring algorithm to produce
the scores the ads are selected ranked
and scored and then the user clicks on
the ads and then the process will repeat
for a new user so you can think about
from the advertiser perspective they're
gonna place a bid and then this process
is going to happen over and over again
and one of the key features of this is
that the environments actually very
stochastic from the perspective of the
advertiser because new scores are drawn
every single time a query comes along
other people are running out of budgets
there's all sorts of randomness in the
system so they actually face a smooth
problem the early kind of game theory
literature on this did not account for
the smoothness and it actually made the
problem much harder and people got kind
of completely off on an irrelevant
tangent about multiple assisity of
equilibrium and all other stuff that had
nothing to do with the real-world
problem so just to kind of see it's a
generalized second price auction they
pace a place of per click bid there's an
estimated revenue bid which is the
Quality Score times the bid the price
per click is the minimum price they
could have been and still maintain to
their position so if you think about
tying their estimated revenue bids you
get to the price per click and then this
is how much revenue you get from each
position and one of the sources of
randomness is just to show are these
quality scores are random from the
perspective of the bidder which is what
makes the problems smooth so previous
work as I mentioned kind of got hung up
on the discreteness in an earlier paper
we developed the theory of the
continuous bidding as strategies
developed the
Oh Librium showed existence and
uniqueness and we estimated this model
under the assumption that everybody was
maximizing profit per click which is
from Chrome clicks which is kind of the
standard place to start and I said we
didn't do a good job fitting the data
out of sample for the reasons I
mentioned but just to show you how this
is that our new model is going to
incorporate that model is one component
so let me sort of show you how it works
and give you a sense of how you use
behavioral assumptions to infer
valuations so here on that on the x-axis
is the expected quantity of clicks what
you can read directly off of the data is
the average cost for click as a function
of how many clicks you want to get well
you don't directly read that off the
data what happens is you can if I take
all the auction data I can rerun all the
options using the auction logic because
I understand the logic different levels
of bids and as the bidder increases
their bid they're gonna be in a higher
position more often they're gonna get a
higher fraction of the available clicks
and but they're also going to pay a
prior higher price as they move up the
auction so each time they raise their
bid they're gonna be more likely to be
and say this position rather than this
position and playing a higher price but
they're going to be averaging that out
and so if I then if I if I if I can
basically do this this is not really a
statistical estimation it's kind of
numerical approximation from what's what
that what I see in the data
I can then numerically differentiate it
and get the marginal cost curve so in
our first paper we actually did this all
nonparametric lee and did the numerical
differentiation in the in the second
paper we actually used a log normal
functional form because that made our
results much more stable and it fit the
data reasonably well so that we didn't
end up with irregularities in this
numerical derivative once I have the
numerical derivative this is the
marginal cost curve okay then I have
something that looks like we teach in
econ 101 except for your cell you're
buying instead of selling and so in
particular the optimal solution from an
average profit maximizing advertisers
perspective is that the value per click
should be equal to the marginal costs
per click that's the first-order
condition for
some ization so if I saw this this
advertiser buying a half of the
available clicks and I have estimated
this marginal cost curve then I can say
all right what value would at this
observed quantity would set the value
equal the marginal cost and that's the
Green Line that's what I'm inferring and
so that's like about point seventy so
I'm inferring that in order for this the
bid that they chose and therefore the
quantity that they chose to have been
optimal they must have had this value
and this is the profit they get the
value per click minus the average cost
per click this is the rectangle they're
trying to optimize and that to maximize
they want to make that rectangle big and
value equal marginal cost is what does
that so this is what we did in our first
paper and we invert it we figured out
these values let me just skip over that
so let me show you the the data that we
have now and we're gonna build a more
richer model so we've got nine months of
data in our sample and we have roughly
about eighty thousand accounts on
average in each month then each account
has lots of listings so we have
somewhere between like one and a half
million and 3 million listings and our
data set in every month in a listing is
like a keyword bid so it's like auto
insurance exact match and then a bid
associated with it that's the level at
which we have the bids they're there at
active on average the listings kind of
come and go so they're not all there for
the entire time so it's not a completely
balanced panel and then this is the
average number of queries per listing so
each listing on average is showing up
not very often but that's a very skewed
distribution there's a lot of very big
ones and then a few ones that don't get
a lot of action and then a bunch they
don't get a lot of action at all all
right so the empirical facts so there's
a lot of heterogeneity and participation
there's also a lot of infrequent bid
changers
there's also listings created for very
different purposes like some of them
they'll be actively managing and some
they won't some of them are on like eBay
bidding on eBay and then they're gonna
set a very high bid and just leave it
alone other ones are going to be like
broad match where they don't really know
where they're getting matched and they
tend to optimize those
indifferently so today I'm going to show
you what we do for frequent bid changers
and because that's the easiest one to
explain so what are the advertisers know
well first of all they can see their
average clicks average CTR average CPC
and so on through the online tool but in
addition there are tools that allow them
to to basically do counterfactuals so
the tool will actually let them see what
would happen at different bids they're
noisy but they'll give you some idea and
the advertisers can also experiment they
use a bunch of tools that help them
optimize I love some of these things
they do like you know a self learning
algorithm with flexible configuration
and so on and like you know optimization
is like part of it which is very funny
to an economist because like what is
this to afford should just be optimizing
like that certainly be a feature and
that should be the point but anyways so
one of the very interesting things is
like when they when you when you reuse
these tools they actually give you lots
of goals
so like one goal could be to like
maximize profits from actions another
one could be to get the right position
another one is to try to spend a budget
efficiently so you can actually tell
these tools to do a lot of different
things and so that's something that
we're gonna want to account for some of
the some of the funny things are that
some of these goals are actually like
like just don't make sense under any
circumstances but they are offered
anyways which is kind of funny but so
anyway so let me talk about the ones
we're gonna look at today I'm just gonna
show you three different objective
functions one is that they maximize
profits from clicks one is that they
want to get impressions which is often
what they say they want to do with their
brand keywords and also I'm gonna let
them have an incremental value from
being at the top of the page which is
again another thing that they often try
to do and their action space is a space
of bids so for each bidder I can write
down their total expenditure the click
probability the probability of appearing
that's an impression and also the
probability of appearing at the top and
so I can write down the profits from
these different objectives I mean the
notation isn't too important it's just
to say that for each of the objectives
profit from clicks from impressions and
from appearing in the top position
they're all functions the bids they're
all smooth functions of bids because of
the uncertainty so I can differentiate
all these objectives
and for each of them I can invert them
to figure out for each bid what values
would have made those optimal so the
model is basically the the the the
bidders there's going to be latent
variables it's gonna be a Bayesian model
so I can think of the bay the bidder is
having a latent type but I just don't
know which one they are and then there's
going to be parameters for those
objectives the distribution of of the
environment changes over time but the
bidders are learning that and figuring
it out and so what I'm gonna zoom is
that whenever they change their bid
their bid is optimal okay and so the way
that I'm going to infer which type of
objective they are is I'm gonna say
suppose I see them the over nine months
they keep you know they they make the
world changes frequently and I can
observe that happening I see them
responding to those changes in the world
I can see we suppose one of the
objectives if I assume they were trying
to get in the top position their
behavior doesn't make any sense at all
like I would have to have their their
their values varying wildly in order to
make that objective make sense but then
on the other hand maximizing profit from
clicks I might have their value for
click being relatively stable over time
to be able to explain their behavior
from a value per click model so I'm
gonna use stability of the of the
preference parameters is my metric for
saying which objective makes the most
sense it's the I'm gonna say the
objective doesn't make sense if you
would need wildly varying preference
parameters to explain the data now this
is obviously like a strong assumption we
can project we haven't actually done
this in the estimation I'm going to show
you but we can actually build an
underlying stochastic process to allow
those costs to vary by time by day of
week and I have all the data about what
the other bidders are doing so there's I
can build an underlying stochastic
process into that estimation because
that assumption that they're just
constant over a nine month period is
obviously not reasonable okay so the
idea of identification is basically that
at the instant of the bid change the
bidders is optimal I'm going to recover
the parameters for each possible
objective function I'm going to use the
stability criterion to choose the
objective function and and then what I'm
what again as I mentioned I can
allow those preferences to vary over
time I set all that and so in little
more specifically I'm gonna what I'm the
way I'm going to do this from a
computational perspective is I there's
all these components of the objective
function and I'm gonna estimate all the
derivatives of all of those components
and actually to do this I'm gonna go
query by query since I'm I'm I'm
modeling the uncertainty for each query
I can take the derivative with all of
the different components and I can do
that in a parallelized way so I've got
you know whatever these like 300 million
things and I can parameters but I'm
gonna be able to figure them out because
for each individual user query I'm gonna
calculate a derivative and I can just
take all these derivatives and then
aggregate them back up again
and so then so basically we do this huge
thing on the clusters but then we can
pull it off and on a server do my
Bayesian estimation once I have all the
derivatives so the Bayesian estimator I
remember prior over the types the
likelihood is defined for the process of
the transition of preferences over time
and the overall likelihood is a mixture
of the likelihood of the different
objective functions what I'm going to
output is the posterior over both the
parameters of the objective functions
and the type of the bidder and this is
this is nice relative to say frequentist
approaches simon and really understand
some bitter as well and other bidders
I'm not going to really have a lot of
data about them and so I'm not really
going to know much about them I'm in
this in what I'm showing today I'm only
gonna use bidders who change frequently
and who don't do it like every Monday so
that I can sort of say that it looks
like they're actually being optimal
about what they're doing and I'm gonna
assume that they look at the most recent
data when they when they change their
bed so the idea is like they're
monitoring and then opes it look like
the world changed I'm gonna log in and
and change my bed so the Bayesian model
is going to basically be a classifier
over the objective functions and so
luckily this is a very sharp classifier
so I'm basically for almost everybody
I'm getting that either there there have
an objective function or they don't have
an objective function now this is a
little bit it maybe looks a little
better than it is because I mean these
models make very different predictions
so it's sort of unlikely that they're
both all going to give
seemed kind of goodness-of-fit so it's a
you know but but but nonetheless it's
good there's a little bit of mass here
in the middle okay so then what are some
of the the main results so one of the
things this is really the chart that
actually got us the most excited or made
us feel like okay we had a model that
really worked we looked at the different
match types of the bids so exact matches
eBay bidding on eBay and only on eBay or
like bidding exactly on auto insurance
phrase is that the search term had to
have that same phrase and broad like
basically like you could be on anything
it's just something that the search
engine thinks is sort of like your query
and so usually for broad match you're
not thinking about being in the top
position you don't even really know
where you're being shown or you don't
really understand it very well so you
tend to do that as like more like just
generic direct response where you're
just looking at the data and optimizing
well the bidders are caring a lot about
how they appear on exact match listings
because a lot of that is brand and so
what we see is that most of the exact
match are like about half we're
classifying them is valuing being in the
top position well for broad match we're
seeing more than half looking like
they're valuing clicks and so that's
roughly sort of what we would expect
it's what the advertisers tell us and so
you know we found that really reassuring
then we could break out our results by
by industry and we found that like autos
financial services and travel and
transportation look like they were
really optimizing for clicks and again
these are industries they're pretty
sophisticated that are generally big
high-value how big automated in-house
like I'm on the board of Expedia they
have a huge in-house thing where they're
optimizing their search spend and in a
in a very scientific way while over here
like entertainment and investments are
high on the impressions and you can
think of that as maybe being again a
little bit more brandish advertising we
find that a lot of heterogeneity with a
booth in accounts so we find that about
this is the fraction of the listings
within the account the the empirical
probability for all this things within
the account
the same as each other and roughly like
a little more than half of the accounts
are like every all the listings look
like the same type but there's actually
a lot of heterogeneity within accounts
and that's again consistent with what we
expect and and there's actually not a
lot where everybody in the account is
just trying to be in the top position
which again is sort of what we expect
let me just to say a few more words now
I'm actually don't really know when I'm
stopping because we started late but
something like that ok so then the final
thing that and this is one of the
reasons we're still working on this
because we've been trying to incorporate
a lot of extensions to make the model
more and more realistic one of the
really important things but that
actually required a fair bit of change
in our terms of our computation is
dealing with budget constraints so in
practice many advertisers have budget
constraints and so I said before like
everything was all separable like I
could go out and calculate all these
derivatives you know kind of user query
by user query and then aggregate
everything up and I you know I say oh
I've got you know millions and millions
of listings but each of those was done
completely independently so I could have
written this paper with 200 listings or
3 million but I didn't do anything
differently it just sounds really cool
that I'm estimating like you know 50
million parameters but it's actually
like not any different than doing you
know a couple thousand in terms of comp
you know except it's just I need more
computers but one thing that makes
things non-separable is budget
constraints and that because that then
links the different listings in through
the in the account through Lagrange
multiplier so what happens on one
listing would make you want to bid less
on another listing and so if you just
have one listing you can't actually
distinguish that law that Lagrange
multiplier which is going to make you
want to sort of bid less aggressively
from just having a lower value per click
so I need a more complicated estimation
scheme for that and then I also have to
worry about the budget constraints
changing over time so what we basically
do here is we
we use a Bayes empirical likelihood
approach where we have these moment'
conditions and one of the moment
conditions is the covariance between the
bid change for the listing and the
spending on other listings in the same
account so if they didn't have a budget
constraint the spending on other
listings on the same account shouldn't
be correlated with the spending on this
listing they should be the bid on this
listing they should be independent but
if they do have a budget constraint that
would create the link and so it's that
link that's gonna allow us to back out
how much this budget constraint is is
binding this is a trickier thing to do
for a whole bunch of reasons and you
also have to start worrying more about
well gosh like maybe there's something
else that's happening at the account
level so we tried to bring in a lot more
control variables for for things that
are happening on these these keywords we
so we want to essentially find something
looks a little bit more like an
instrument so we don't want to we don't
want to say oh gosh this advertiser is
spending more on red roses so that means
that there and that affected what they
did on pink roses therefore their budget
constraint because maybe there's
something going on that's making them
bid differently for red roses and pink
roses but if if users were searching
more for one of those those queries or
if something was happening outside of
their control on one of those other
queries then that would give me like
cleaner better variation to identify the
budget constraints so we've we've we've
been trying a bunch of different methods
to get sort of the cleanest possible
variation for identifying the budget
constraints in the bayes posterior is
this mixture of empirical likelihoods so
what do you do with all of this well
then as we can you can deliver on the
promises I made at the beginning for
example I can predict what will happen
if I say I make my click prediction
better or I make better matching
algorithms for ads and I sent out the
options I could accurately predict that
the bidders will once they realize
there's not as much competition will
further reduce their prices
another thing specific to this model is
that gosh like I found them the whole
auction is designed for people for
advertisers who care about clicks we
don't allow them to
to express a value for impression we
don't have a product that says
automatically bid on your behalf to stay
in the top position so being or Google
could offer that kind of product and
that would improve efficiency for the
advertisers and so we can we can very
smart design implications once you
understand how much of the market just
wants to be in the top position and
generally you know you want to weigh
welfare for advertisers with high cost
of optimization the fact that we see
advertisers not making changes even
though we think they should we should
realize that we're inflicting costs on
them when when we change the system too
much and make the system too variable
okay so just conclusions there's lots
and lots of heterogeneity in this
ecommerce application and I think you
would see the same for sellers on eBay
or advertisers on Facebook you know
marketplace sellers on Amazon highly
heterogeneous actors but modeling them
is super important in a world where it's
really hard to do a/b testing so this
set of techniques can can classify the
advertisers get parameters of their
objective and really help guide your
thinking about how to design the
marketplace better but I have to say
like out of everything I ever did in
Tuck firms like this kind of had the
least buy-in because people don't
understand all these assumptions they
understand an a/b test even if the a/b
test is like patently blatantly
obviously wrong and like idiotically
wrong there people are happier with that
a B test the a/b test is essentially
holding the advertiser behavior fixed so
you have ask yourself but I'd rather
make an assumption out of this model
where I made a lot of bad assumptions
but I'm assuming the advertisers are
doing something or what I rather use
data that did not allow the advertisers
to respond at all and actually just
assume the advertisers never respond to
anything well except you know it seems
pretty clear that damina this is sort of
better but it's just it's just not you
know I've had some people in industry
get excited about it and buy into it for
periods of time but I think it's just
very hard any because partly because
like it just doesn't really fit into the
classic supervised machine learning kind
of paradigm of you know having a test
set and sort of seeing how it all works
out
so that's a that's my my caveat at the
end of this I love that the research has
been really fun for me
but it hasn't been as impactful as some
other things I've done so thanks